Sathya Narayanan: Okay, so what we are going to do is we are going to do a, two-people breakout room. Nancy or Nicholas, like, somebody can… you have breakout room feature, right? Like, if you could, not include the host.
Sathya Narayanan: co-hosts, but create two people rooms while I'm talking.
Sathya Narayanan: One thing we really want to emphasize, even though we built this dojo, as much as possible, we don't want you to just talking to AI by itself.
Sathya Narayanan: Right? Like, that is not the goal. Like, that reduces your human ability to kind of connect, and there is… yeah, it's pretty good, but it is not…
Sathya Narayanan: everything we need, right? So we want it to be always something where you are doing it in partnership with
Sathya Narayanan: Not… maybe not always, but at least 50% of the time, you are doing it in partnership with another human being, right? I work with AI by myself a lot, but I also try to make sure that I have time with Nicholas and Nancy and Jeff and, like, I'm talking to people. Otherwise, I'll just become not so smart. I don't know.
Sathya Narayanan: So, what we are going to do is we are going to go into a breakout room with two of you.
Sathya Narayanan: You're gonna take turns, you're gonna share your screen, be on webcam.
Sathya Narayanan: And each of you are going to go through the activity, right? Like, you are going to try to answer, but you're talking to the human being also. Hey, it's asking this question, this is how I'm thinking about answering, here is what comes to my mind. Okay, let's see what it says.
Sathya Narayanan: Right? Or maybe the other person may have a suggestion on how to say it. Then you… you kind of make the adjustment. And then you… so you are… it's kind of a three-people conversation now, but two human beings and one AI.
Sathya Narayanan: Right? It is still a three-people team, but it is two human beings and one AI. We are going to do that, so that is the plan here, right?
Sathya Narayanan: One thing about the tool is, you see this button here? So this is… there is no backend here.
Sathya Narayanan: there's no server on which the chat is getting stored, so we are not tracking it ourselves directly. The chat is all local, it's storing in your own computer. If you click on save, and you can say save as JSON, it will, save the file into a… into your
Sathya Narayanan: download folder. We'd like you to upload this on Canvas, right? On Canvas, there is a human plus AI connection assignment. In this, we would like you to upload the JSON when you are done, right? So go through the conversation, and then save it and submit.
Sathya Narayanan: So we are at, like, 7 o'clock, we're gonna open the breakout rooms, let's make this… 18 minutes.
Sathya Narayanan: So about, like, 9 minutes for one person, and then… so that means, like, 7 minutes for one person for… or 8 minutes for one person for conversation, for a minute for them to save and download and upload.
Sathya Narayanan: And then switch role. The second person shares their screen, uses their dojo, starts a fresh conversation, and kind of picks one of these, and then has a conversation.
Sathya Narayanan: And then, in 7 or 8 minutes, pause.
Sathya Narayanan: Save, download, and submit, and then we'll close the room. We'll come back and talk a little bit.
Sathya Narayanan: talk about what are the other things you are going to do, like, what homework you have. I'm using air quotes for homework, because it's not a class, there's no grades, things we think we should do, and then we will wrap up, right? That's the plan. So, think about, like, kind of 9 minutes per person.
Sathya Narayanan: If the instructions didn't make sense, please stay back and ask questions, and we are happy to help, and we can come to your breakout room also and help.